[Music]
and there's the reason why I'm getting
the [__] off with everything
so guys this video was sent to me of a
woman who seemed like she's distressed
on a plane there are two footages from
different angles showing her and she
seems like there is something or some
kind of a presence in that plane and
she's disturbed by it and she wants to
leave the plane in another angle as you
can see brown scissors which we're going
to watch for ourselves the question that
needs to ask is the following what is
this let's watch this footage brothers
and sisters and come back and see what
is it as Muslims we believe in something
called the Jinn kind which is also known
as the one that is not seen so brothers
and sisters inshallah here's the video
the disturbing videos inshallah if you
are scared of stuff like this I
recommend you not to watch it but Hamill
if you're watching it make sure you do
it at card you're praying Salah and
inshallah protects us here's the footage
I'm telling you I'm getting the [__] off
and there's the reason why I'm getting
believe it
leave it but I am telling you telling me
right now
there is not real
and you can sit on this plane and you
can fight with him or not I'm not going
to this is a new video made by another
passenger who was on the flight the
woman on the plane was on who became
distraught when she realized she was
supposedly sitting next to a
shape-shifter
okay
[Music]
so guys as you can see and before we go
into the footage brothers and sisters
wallahi every single one of us should
have Quran in our lives every single one
of us should have Quran in our lives
Quran is a shafat is a cure it protects
you from physical and spiritual harms
whatever it may be Allah has given it
how many times I'd come here and talk
about the ab qurania get the habit of
building brothers and sisters the habit
of reading the Quran it is an app that
subhanallah changes people's lives they
message me myself and brothers and
sisters I would never recommend
something to you guys I don't believe in
we put our qurans on the Shelf but we
never read it download the app it
doesn't need credit card get the free
trial and build a habit when brother
Issa passed away may all have mercy on
him his death brought me closer to the
Quran and I asked Allah every time I
read the Quran he benefits from it so
please bear that in mind the description
is in the link below
coming back to this video what is the
Jin kind we know from the Quran and the
Sunnah that they are created we know
that for example the angels are created
from light we know that the Jin kind are
created from smokeless fire and we know
that that the human beings are created
from dust or Earth whatever you want to
call it which there's narration of
eyeshadow which says this so brothers
and sisters Jin kind as you know is a
beings a group of beings or whatever
they are they come in the forms just
like us Muslim Christian Jew and
different faiths yes there are Muslim
jinns there are Christian Gins they are
Jewish Gins and different faiths they
live just like us and brothers and
sisters Allah says in the Quran we have
I have created Mankind and jenkat for no
other reason but to worship me meaning
that they also have to have and errada
they have to have an uncle to be tested
because they're going to be questioned
meaning that they have a functioning we
don't want to call it a mind or whatever
it may be for that matter that they will
be questioned so we know from the Hadith
for the process come into three kinds of
forms number one there are those who
come the shape of snakes or dogs number
two there are those who travel like the
wind and the other ones are those who
literally take rest so we know they come
and that's some of their Natures so
brothers and sisters what's she seeing
there to us we believe that it can be a
gin and they call us call this kind of
mistake and shapeshifters so these are
beings that go into different shapes and
we know that the Jinn and the shayateen
they have those abilities to do that is
it in coincidence so we say subhanallah
it just shows the miraculous nation of
the Quran once again because the Quran
deals with real life problems and how do
you protect yourself from this brothers
and sisters do you pray your Salah you
don't you give do you fast in Ramadan
you don't you're given zakah you don't
do you even do avocado no you don't you
commit major sins yes you are prone and
open it's as good as you being in an
open field and there is a sniper looking
directly at you it's as simple as that
the Unseen ruled is the Unseen World Is
Real the Quran the Lord has told you
this Allah has told you this we know in
Surah Jinn that Allah mentions that a
group of the jinns came and heard the
Quran and they came to believe they came
for Iman we even know situations of
people who are doing exorcism and the
Jinn that's inside becomes a Muslims
take shahada and leaves this is the
reality we believe in and we have no
doubt certainty that this is the Hub
this is the truth because Allah said it
how much longer are we going to suffer
people having gym possession and other
things why they don't pray that Salah
they don't do the basic rights they
don't give the Allah they don't even do
that another app I tell you to download
is
I'm telling you as a public figure
myself I probably would have been dead
by now I do not you know why because I
know there is Envy I know there is
jealousy I know there is Magic it's it's
out there you have to protect yourself
there are people putting all kinds of
stuff in social media their life Etc
everything looks do you not think we are
human beings do you think I don't have
jealousy Envy do you not think at one
moment of time I have jealous and envy I
do but I seek refuge in Allah but it
shows you what that we are all prone to
have these things it's within us it's a
way of dealing with it now imagine I
have a friend in my life who is so much
blessings going on deep inside shaytan
comes and a good form of jealousy is
that you don't ask Allah that Allah
takes it away from him rather you want
it for yourself but that little jealousy
can give him Hazard even like it can be
unintentionally
that's why do you have care because even
your friend that loves you you can give
yourself evil eye your your wife can
give you evil eye subhanallah let alone
your friend it's human nature it doesn't
make them bad it's human nature
subhanallah and if you're handsome like
my brother and jabi subhanallah the
wives were giving them evil every day
may Allah preserve them but Jokes Aside
guys protect yourself inshallah two apps
I recommend you to download the Quran
reading must you must have Quran in your
life every day even if it's for five
minutes and the qurani app allows you to
do that number two the avocado Fajr read
it and before I said you read it it will
protect you all the way around and sadly
you will not be a frequent inflicted by
this and it might be a gin that's
probably fallen in love with this woman
it happens it happens these things
happen and guess what I also learned
that about said may Allah bless him that
when you're even taking your clothes off
going naked say Bismillah it is a form
of covering for you
do not see you our religion has given us
pragmatic practical Solutions even to
the Unseen alhamdulillah we have a
religion that deals with all of our
affairs from disputes to divorce to
business to whatever it may be to even
the Unseen I'm going to leave that with
you guys inshallah brothers and sisters
may Allah bless you guys inshallah and
protect us and if this woman is watching
this we invite you to Islam do you have
and Allah protection only physically and
spiritually unless he is deemed that you
are going to be inflicted with something
till next time
share this video with your friends and
families so they can be an awareness
don't forget to download